- [Voiceover] Go for it.
- What's up, ballers?
Welcome to Real Mature.
Just spilled water on myself.
Anyhow, Real Mature is a show that we make
about things that happen
to you when you grow up,
and one of the things that
happens when you grow up
is your relationship with
your friends changes,
so we have three different
stories about friendship today.
One of 'em involves Ella
- What should I say?
- Just say hey.
- Hey.
- Cool.
Let's get into it.
(snazzy music)
One thing that we were thinking about
when we were talking about friendship,
is I asked a question
to a bunch of the people
who work on the show.
Do you know why your friends like you?
Like, do you guys know
why your friends like you?
- No.
- No, not really.
- Like, do you ever thought about it,
or thought to ask them?
- I don't know.
That'd just make it weird, I feel like.
- I think it would make it weird.
- What we did is,
we interviewed three
of Ella's friends from
three different parts of
her life, and we asked,
what do you like about Ella?
Why do you want to be friends with her?
The first person we interviewed was
a new friend of yours, Ashly.
- Crossing from like, calling someone,
this is my work friend,
to my friend friend, like,
that's a weird thing, I think.
- It's a grown-up thing that happens.
- Yeah.
- Okay, cool.
You ready to watch?
- Yeah.
- I met Ella about a--
Actually, it was almost two years ago,
and we didn't become friends
until like six months ago.
- Do you remember what
your first impression was?
- Oh, she really nice and chill,
but kind of quiet, which
is hilarious to me now.
- I generally have
like, a lot of thoughts,
and I'm really opinionated,
and I don't want people
to think I'm a bitch.
Honestly.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- So you need to
- [Henry] hold yourself back.
- [Ella] So I definitely
hold myself back.
- I remember being like, oh,
I wanna be friends with Ella,
but not knowing exactly how to.
- Wait, so you had like a friend crush?
- Yeah!
- You had a friend crush on her as well?
- Yeah, she's awesome.
- What she's passionate
about, she's so intense,
and then the rest of her life
is just so fucking chill.
- People, they're like,
you're just, you're chill,
you just have a chill
personality, and I'm like,
cool, I'm glad you think that.
- It's interesting just
like watching this now,
the thought I just had is,
the things that your friends like you for,
are the things that
people who don't like you,
don't like you for.
- It is weird to say like the
thing I don't like about her
is that she doesn't like
herself enough sometimes,
and it's like, dude, you're super cool,
like, just be proud of
that and be into that.
It's why people like you.
- [Henry] Do you think that's true?
- [Ella] It's true.
Yeah, it's true.
I don't know why I'm
so critical of myself,
but it's awesome to hear that,
and it just makes me feel so much better.
- Okay, well we're gonna look at
a couple more of your
friends, what they had to say,
but first off, we're gonna
go see our friend, Abe,
who has another story for us,
but he's in another building,
so we gotta go get him,
so, you guys ready?
- Yeah.
- You all ready?
- [Voiceover] Ready
- [Voiceover] Let's do it.
- Alright.
(classy music)
- [Henry] What's up, Abe?
- [Abe] Hello.
- [Henry] You ready to tell
us about Brother Orange?
- [Abe] I am ready, yes.
- Alright, let's go over here.
- Let's do it.
Hey guys.
- [Ella] Hey
- Hey.
- [Abe] Hey Ella, hey Henry.
- [Ella] How's it going?
- So, we're not load
- No, I like being summoned
from my editing booth.
Good to stand up every now and then.
- You're working on a
pretty long documentary,
like, the longest we've made in a while,
about one of our
colleagues, Matt, and like,
a super interesting friend that you made.
- Yeah, it's a totally unique friendship.
I don't think anything like
this has ever happened before.
- What happened was Matt lost his phone.
A year later, in his iCloud,
he started to see photos
from the person who had his old phone.
He wrote a post about, like,
seeing those photos on his phone,
and that became a wildly
successful story in China,
and the Chinese internet
then found the guy
and there was this incredible
internet pressure for
them to meet, and then,
once they met, they became friends.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, you have a piece
now that is just a segment
of the film about when they
realized they were friends.
What do you think about it, Colin?
- I like it.
(all laugh)
- Cool.
- Cool, we're into it, alright,
well, let's watch this piece.
- [Matt] So, right now
we're in the East Village.
I live in the East Village.
So, this is literally
where I had my phone taken.
Basically, my phone went from
where we are right now to
China, to southern China.
Like, random southern
China, to Brother Orange.
I'm just really open to everything.
We cancelled all of
our hotel reservations,
because they told us to.
We have no idea what's gonna happen.
We're just, I'm talking through an app
that translates for me to him,
and we're talking through Chinese Twitter,
which he's speaking in Chinese on,
and then I ask people, I say,
can you help me translate that?
Like, that's the way
that we're communicating.
I have no idea what's
about to happen right now.
- [Woman in blue] Oh my god, Matt,
you're just like, waving to people.
- [Matt] Oh my gosh, Brother Orange!
Hey!
- Welcome to China.
- Yeah, thank you!
- [Voiceover] He's excited too.
- It's amazing just like, meet each other.
- It's just so, so amazing.
It's bizarre.
It's really bizarre.
Brother Orange is a really
nice guy, genuinely.
It's been less than 24 hours,
but I feel like if, say,
I was with him for like a month,
I feel like we would have a
bunch of social cues by then.
- He's like his big brother,
taking him all the way.
- I feel more of a
connection to Brother Orange.
- What kind of guy is Matt?
What is he like?
- We have fun with each other.
Without words, we can still
have fun and laugh at things,
and you notice things,
and you point at it,
and you'll be like, look at that thing,
and that's communication right there,
and that's how we communicate.
Yeah, I don't know.
He's just a really fun guy.
(laughing and shouting)
- [Voiceover] I give up.
- [Voiceover] And it's
funny because we've moved on
in our relationship,
me and Brother Orange.
We're comfortable with
awkward silences, and so,
we'll be just like, sitting
and no one will feel
pressured to say anything,
which is honestly,
everyone else, it's the
first step to a friendship,
is when you don't have to say anything.
We don't speak the same language,
and still I feel this honest
warmth from him, honest.
We are like, legitimately friends.
The Chinese really believe in,
y'know, fate, and good luck.
For some reason, I meant to
come here, and for some reason,
Orange Brother was meant to meet me,
and there's some weird fate
thing, whether that's just,
we're meant to just go through
this amazing experience,
and I'm not saying like, this is gonna be,
something's gonna happen because of it,
it's just that we're meant to go
have this amazing experience together.
- [Voiceover] When do
you feel like you knew
that you and Matt were truly friends?
- Bad, bad, bad, bad, bad.
- So, when's the full movie gonna be done?
- I am working on it.
- Alright, wanna go back to work?
- Yeah.
- Wait, wait, wait, I
gotta good bit right there.
- What do you got?
- You know what Abe stands for, right?
- [Ella and Henry] What?
- Always be editing.
- That's not gonna make it into the cut.
Okay.
- But yeah, I always be editing.
- [Ella] Bye, Abe.
(smooth music)
- What the story of Brother
Orange reminds me of
is the idea that like, a
lot of the friends you make,
you make by like, going through
an experience with somebody,
and so, we have another friend of yours,
who we're gonna watch talk about
how she became friends with you,
and you guys went through
the experience of college together.
What do you think she's gonna say?
- I dunno.
God, college.
I have no idea.
- Alright, ready?
(coughs)
- [Henry] You okay?
- I'm good, had a moment.
I'm good.
- Okay.
- I met Ella through college.
We were potluck suite-mates.
- It's just the fact that you're Skyping
with one of my best friends right now.
- Yeah, it's really weird.
- So, you're just drinking a beer,
and just like, hearing about my life.
- I knew she was really cool,
and I wanted to be friends with her,
so I'm glad that we
sort of became friends,
and stuck together all of college.
We continued to live together
until she moved to LA.
- Wait, so you saw her on
Facebook, and you're like
she's cool, I wanna be friends with her.
- Yeah, I looked through
all her profile pictures,
and I was like, I'm gonna
get along with this girl.
- People have friend crushes on you.
- That so crazy,
because I don't think anyone
wants to be friends with me.
- She's definitely not afraid of people.
She's not afraid of being herself
or tossing out a really quirky idea,
but she's also one of the most
laid-back people that I've ever met.
She kinda just rolls out
of bed and she's that cool.
Do you think if you met
today, just at a bar,
like just basically
like, two friends groups,
sort of like meeting together,
and you guys started talking,
do you think you would hit it off?
What do you think she's gonna say?
- I don't know.
- Okay, let's see what she says.
- Yeah, for sure.
- I mean, this makes me happy.
This is such a weird show, guys.
I'm like sweating.
(chill music)
- The next video we're gonna watch
is one that Colin made, so Colin,
why don't you tell us your story?
- I moved to Los Angeles about a year ago,
and I was thirty years old.
I didn't really know anybody,
and it was the first
time in a very long time
that I had to make some friends,
so Henry told me to make some friends,
and I did it the best I knew how.
- How?
- I put up some fliers.
- What?!
(all laugh)
(jazzy music)
- [Colin] My mom didn't
like this idea very much.
She said it seemed kinda dangerous,
but it only took about 20 minutes
before I started meeting
other people on the street,
and of course they were
making a video too.
- [Voiceover] I'm Jenny.
- Let's break the wall.
- Hey!
- [Colin] So I followed these two guys
around the corner to a building
that I actually thought was
abandoned, and it's not,
but, well I guess that
kinda sounds sketchy
now that I say it out loud.
(peppy music)
This is insane.
- [Voiceover] That is a weird shout.
- [Guy in Grey] Just gonna play it out
like it was all planned.
Actually, Buzzfeed came in
today to jump with Ryan.
- Our studio, it's always
been a lot of local people.
- [Colin] I was feeling pretty confident
in my plan at this point.
I mean, I didn't really do anything,
and I was already getting
tours of big, cool art studios,
and jumping on trampolines.
- Alright guys, cool, thanks.
Nice to meet you.
- And you found me on Instagram?
- Yeah, I'll put it on for
you, write a little thing.
- Alright, to the lake.
(peppy music)
- Wave, Jenny.
I started getting a little
cocky with my skills.
I'm gonna introduce myself
to this gentleman over here.
- [Colin] Hey, this is Andrew.
- Hey, people.
- We met Andrew while
he was eating breakfast.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause he was getting
a late start today.
- Yeah.
- There's probably like people
sitting around everywhere
who are like, aw man,
I wish had more people to
hang out with on Friday.
- Right, you know,
who are thinking the same thing
and wanting the same thing.
Really, I think it's,
you have to be sort of
open in your possibilities,
as cliche as that sounds.
I've only been out here for an hour,
and I feel like I'm gonna get heat stroke.
Andrew and I had a lovely afternoon,
and I went home thinking my day was over,
but when I checked my e-mail,
I discovered that my fliers
were actually working.
I'm trying to pick out a beer,
'cause I got invited to a potluck tonight.
- Hello?
- [Colin] Hey!
- Colin, get up here, man!
Nice to to meet you!
- [Colin] Nice to meet you too.
That's JP.
He saw one of my fliers by the lake.
- How are ya? Come on in!
- [Colin] Thanks!
- [Voiceover] Did you guys,
how do you all know each other?
- We're gonna have pulled
pork sandwiches, guys.
Ah! No!
Just bros, meat, and video games.
I totally forgot how much
I miss this kind of thing.
- Donkey Kong's slow, right?
- Yeah, but he does hit hard.
- Dang it!
I lost a second befo--
Well, I'm first out.
- I think that's her.
Sophie?
- Oh yes, hello, hi.
- [Colin] It's pretty bold for
a woman to call on a flier,
but after a couple beers and a few tacos,
we both got a little more
comfortable with each other,
and started talking a bit about friendship
and what it really means.
And then, when we got on the subject
of making friends as an adult,
she said something that
really struck a chord with me,
and I haven't really forgotten about it.
- I guess the hardest
part about making friends
is admitting that you
want to make new friends,
because you feel like
when you're an adult,
you should already have friends,
and you should have already
found your place in the world,
but really, you like,
don't know what's going on
at all, and that's okay.
- [Colin] Right there.
That's when she nailed
it, and she's right.
The only thing that really gets in the way
of making new friends is ego.
I mean, nobody really has
this shit figured out.
So, I decided to start calling back
the new friends I've made,
because I realized that that
was a lot scarier than meeting new people.
Meeting new friends was
starting to feel easy,
and that's when I got a call from Jessie,
an Echo Park native who was
looking for a sofa on Craig's
List, and found me instead.
After a few tacos, we
hit it off immediately.
- If I need it, I'll get
a haircut right there,
Casanova's number two.
- That's where you go?
- Yeah.
- [Colin] I learned something important
from all my new friends.
I realized that it's just not that weird
to call a friendly-looking
dude on a flier.
It pays to just put yourself out there,
and, you know, make the connection.
- You're just talking
because I drive a moped.
- [Colin] And yeah...
- 'Cause I drive a moped.
- [Colin] New friends have perks.
(victorious music)
(smooth music)
- Alright, so, speaking of friends,
are you ready to watch one
of your oldest friends?
- [Ella] Julia's known me through
different periods of my life.
- [Henry] She's known you
the longest of these three.
- [Ella] Yeah, so, it'll
be interesting to see
if she has a similar view of me.
- I met Ella in seventh grade.
I don't remember my first impression.
She was kind of quiet,
kind of like the weird girl in the corner.
- [Henry] She was a
weird girl in the corner.
- Yeah, but I kind of was too,
so I think that's why we clicked.
- Why am I the quiet, weird one?
- I think one of my first
memories of her is in school.
We were playing with large water bottles.
- Of course she's gonna tell this story.
This is, I think about this a lot.
It's when I smacked her
in the face with a bottle
and she started crying, right?
- A water jug, exactly, and she ended up
smashing me in the face with one of them.
So, that was like my
first real memory of Ella,
was me being in pain.
- Of course she tells that story.
I remember just being like, well,
never gonna have friends again,
'cause my new friend is crying now
and she'll hate me forever.
- [Henry] What do you like
about Ella, as a person?
- The first thing that came to
my mind is her impulsiveness.
She just decides she
wants to do something,
she doesn't over-think
it, and she does it.
- I wanna note that this is, I think,
the third person who has
called you impulsive.
- Yeah, I never thought that about myself.
- [Henry] What does your
friendship look like in 20 years?
- We're gonna be friends forever.
Yeah, whether that's
long-distance friendship,
like we've done in the past.
I still have a friend crush on her.
- You still have a friend crush on her?
- Yeah, I still wanna be her friend.
(groovy music)
- Do you feel closer to your friends now,
that we did this with?
- [Ella] I feel like I,
weirdly know more about myself,
just from what they were saying.
It's amazing to hear that
they really do like me for who I am,
and want to be friends with me.
- Remember that friendship is a process,
and you'll be better if you're
like, intentional about it,
and actually think about your friends,
as opposed to just like
going through life,
taking friendship for granted,
kids.
- Babes.
- Bros.
- [Henry] Pretty good way to wrap it up.
Thank you guys for watching.
What it do?
- What it do?!
- What it do.
- [Henry] This episode of
Real Mature was produced
by the BuzzFeedIRL team,
including me, Ryan B,
Colin, Abe, and Michelle.
Thanks to birocratic, CMA
Music, and Nkato for the beats,
Jesse for the graphic help,
and everyone who in the video.
(cool music)